Creating individual triangles by hand is pretty painful, as you probably noticed
from the exercises so far. The most common way to generate geometric objects is
to use a modeling program. Writing such program is the bread and butter for the
company I work for, Auto Desk. Here, I'm using 3 studio max to create a number
of basic objects including the tea polyhedron. There are plenty of other ways to
acquire models. For example, laser scanners can be used to find a cloud of
points. This data is then processed to make a mesh. Another method is to take a
series of photos and have a program derive the shape of the object from these.
Whatever process is used you normally end up with the geometric mesh of
triangles. Within Web GL on 3JS, there's a whole process where you can take a
mesh in some 3D file format and convert it to a form that Web GL can read. I
could spend the next few units discussing this process, but it's not all that
relative to interactive rendering itself. Take a look in the additional course
materials for it to learn more about this.